welcome to the 2018 Android developer
summits this is an event for developers
by developers with over two billion
devices three quarters of a trillion
apps downloaded every year androids
developer community is growing hugely we
saw it more than double just in the past
few years so the Android app bundle
makes it much simpler with no additional
developer work needed the app bundle now
makes apps an average of eight percent
smaller to download for m+ devices so
few months ago we announced jetpack the
next generation of Android tools and API
is to accelerate Android application
development today out of the top 1000
applications in active development on
Play Store 798 already using jetpack
they are already being used in over
38,000 applications all the way the new
beta for Android studio 3 3 was just
released moments ago reducing the number
of crashes pains and memory leaks fixing
user impacting bugs and investing our
infrastructure and tools we're bringing
the full tower of Android studio 2 promo
s early next year we simply could not do
this without you so thank you
you
[Music]